civilian just walking around maybe I'm
not conscious yet but I'm only wearing a
man thong and paint hey guys my name is
Eric Escobar and today I'm going to be
walking around the city wear nothing but
body paint
I've always been like a pretty big heavy
guy actually suffered a back injury they
gave me kind of a weird limp and because
of that I couldn't really work out I
couldn't really exercise I'm not try to
make excuses but I definitely know that
affected me in a way where I couldn't be
as active and I did gain a ton of weight
do you kind of thrown this image
constantly of how the perfect you should
look like because my size I could never
be that perfect image
you're not the cool kid when you're the
big kid kind of like just another person
in the background it really bothered me
until I realize I'm someone who is a
value you can use that to turn whatever
that insecurity is and make it something
great a lot of people think the body
painting is just for supermodels but
it's for everybody not caring what other
people think when your body paint is the
perfect attitude you're walking around
feeling proud as a piece of art so
painting a guy is so much different than
painting a female because you have
different parts to cover up you want
people to focus on the art the design
not the gender of the person being
painted I'm hoping that if anyone sees
it they can be like this guy he's like
250 pounds he's bald but he can rock his
body so so can I
[Music]
[Music]
feels a little freeing doesn't feel like
there's a big difference if you like I'm
just walking around what do you think
what's going on I was like this guy must
have lost the bat or something it's a
pretty bad bet to lose and I saw you
welcome our street in the body pain is
normal I see it every day below I think
I would do it you live once so you got a
do I love that Yolo I don't know if my
younger self would have necessarily done
this because when we're kids were always
like super awkward and super
self-conscious as an adult I'm really
happy I got to do it a lot of people
came in with a lot of positivity saying
that I was inspirational it was
something that was nice but I didn't
care about hearing I know I'm a great
person and I know that I'm gonna chase
after things that I want to do I'm gonna
do the things that make me happy you
don't need to go out and paint yourself
in cool body art and walk around the
street you can just have faith that
you're incredible you're unique
you're the only you that's out there
don't let that stop you from doing
anything that you want to do
you
[Music]